this recently unearthed statue in Egypt
that allegedly 3,000 years old and of
Ramses the second is absolute evidence
of a lost ancient high technology and
it's also evidence of the BS narrative
that the Egyptologist and the minister
of Antiquities of Egypt continued to
throw to the masses let me start with my
first point which is that they claim
that 3,000 years old okay so they don't
know that you cannot carve and eight
stone but they say that although is very
likely to be of ramses ii who lived
three thousand years ago so okay well
really like what makes you think it's
ramses ii or Ramses whoever do you see a
face on this stone I know I sure don't I
mean it's you're a nametag that I fail
to read give me a break
what I see here is a broken statue with
an elongated skull which is really
interesting considering that most
statues of Ramses ramses ii whoever do
not have elongated skulls
now couple do that i found through my
search but then it raises the question
like how do you know this is the same
person it's ridiculous but these
Egyptologists just throw names onto
various statues and claim they know who
they were when they live but they
completely omit the key fundamental
aspect of this statue was which is that
it's made out of quartzite quartzite is
a seven out of ten on the Mohs scale of
hardness diamond is a ten now most
statues in Egypt are made of basalt
which is a six out of ten and then you
have rose granite which is commonly used
which is a six and a half out of ten on
the Mohs scale but quartzite exceeds
that and it must be mentioned that steel
is what's used to cut these types of
stones yet we know that the dynastic
Egyptians did not have steel they had
bronze
well bronze is a combination of copper
and tin you can make it in your kitchen
probably any modern-day stonemason
utilizes steel with diamond bit drills
to cut quartzite rose granite and basalt
so that being said how does the
Egyptians do this what's far more likely
is that the statue predates the dynastic
Egyptians and is part of a civilization
that was wiped out twelve thousand nine
hundred and eighty years ago during the
incredible Cataclysm that happened here
on earth I have a video about this I
mean honestly
for them to just say that oh three
thousand years old and as ramses ii like
are you joking but you can't tell who it
is
now i understand that certain aspects of
the body are very similar to other
statues in egypt so i'm not going to sit
here and tell you that the egyptians did
not make this
but if you really think that they just
scrub down quartzite with sand for like
a hundred years or whatever along it
would take to do so give me a break
there's far more to this story and when
you start connecting the dots on all the
evidence for megalithic structures from
around the world not just Egypt but from
South America Turkey all over the place
you will see that there is absolute
evidence of some sort of lost ancient
high technology that was utilized to
carve these stones there's no other way
now look at these photos here the statue
is massive even the piece of torso that
we lifted out is 3 tons of it in itself
now how are they able to move something
so heavy is one thing but how they were
able to cut and carve one solid piece of
quartzite with the materials that we
know that the dynastic Egyptians had
clearly leaves an absolute gap in what
the current textbooks have been stating
for decades it's quite literally
evidence that the textbooks are
inaccurate and that there's far more to
the story of ancient human civilization
than we're ever taught in schools or
they're actively teaching today anyways
guys I'll leave it at that
like and subscribe I have many other
videos on this topic and a whole other
wide variety of topics as well
I'm Jimmy this right in sight take care
everybody